okay so a couple other things i wanted
to bring up one is
a pain point or kind of a business
opportunity maybe this exists if it
exists tell me because i want to use
this
service so in e-commerce
most e-commerce brands are just local in
their own geography so most are let's
say most u.s ecommerce brands basically
just sell in the us
and then it takes time and then you
start selling in canada and then you
start selling in europe and then
you know but it takes a long time and
the reason it takes a long time is
because of the like international
logistics so for example you want to
ship something to canada
they have to pay like pretty heavy duty
like a import duty
on the product so you sell like a 50
product they're gonna have to pay like
of import taxes in addition to the
shipping so it just becomes like
irresponsible to buy and still some
customers do because they can only get
the product from
the us-based company but it really sucks
and then the company has to like fill
out this form
that says these goods are worth 14 and
then you submit that at the thing and
then
it's just annoying right and so
i think there should be a company so
there's these brands trying to do these
e-commerce roll-ups i think you should
do it differently i think some
enterprising
entrepreneur can basically say look i
will boot up your canadian operation
today i'll boot up your uk operation
your france operation yeah i'll do
europe i'll do
uk i'll do um australia whatever right
so basically say i'll
import your brand today you do no work
so all you have to do
is you need to ship me this product to
this warehouse so here's the address
ship me your products uh i need like you
know whatever your normal inventory is
ship 10 to me and let's see how i do and
basically you get one giant warehouse
where you're warehousing for all the
brands that you're going to work with
and you just say look
uh in exchange for doing this you pay me
no money i will start generating sales
for you
but i want a royalty i want a royalty of
10 cents or 15 cents for every dollar
but what's your point what
like how's this how is this interesting
or new
uh because i don't know of a brand that
that does this that exists so
you know my wife has an e-commerce brand
we sell in the u.s i would love to be
making more money by selling in europe
but the time
the operational overhead to go to europe
right now is just crazy so
why aren't there more people that are
reaching out to e-commerce store owners
and basically saying i will run your
international operation
and make it a low-risk no risk
proposition for them in order to do so
and i think there's a lot of money to be
made given the number of e-commerce
brands in the us
and how you could if you're in brazil or
you're in australia or you're in canada
or wherever
i think you could become the leading
trusted like kind of like
we're we are your canada go to canada go
to market plan for canada
and we just do all the work for you this
is actually quite common in media
so there's business insider india
there's business insider australia
there's business insider germany i
believe
um and then uh um
i think i believe the wall street
journal does the same thing for those
same countries but
it's uh there is buzzfeed france uh
huffpo france huffa australia
it's actually pretty common in media um
so so
is it run out of the us or they hire a
team there or it's
a local team there that just licenses
the brand basically
when they report the revenue it's under
licensing
and so i don't exactly know what that
means though because i was trying
i was thinking about us and i was like
man we have a lot of people who are
uh english as a second language folks uh
in germany
so like uh i guess germany i guess is
one of the most populous
i don't know i don't know numbers i
guess it's one of the most populous
places in europe it's uh very business
focused
so you know the germans liked us um same
with australia
australians loved us and i was like yeah
let's go do it
but what the [__] do i do do i just fly
over there and just start recruiting
like
it's it's crazy i would love to partner
with them and then another thing is
in particular china and japan and
there's actually a whole word for this
there's a word i can't remember what the
word is but there's a word that
describes why it's difficult to break
into japan
um and the reason is is that once it's
hard to break into an island in
particular japan
and i would love to have paid someone to
be like hey can you be my japanese
uh consecuti like my my capo on the
ground
those are all mob terms because i'm into
the mafia now uh
can you be my my guy on the street of
japan and let me know is this good am i
getting the right people i think that's
incredibly interesting
yeah exactly so i'm i'm not saying that
this doesn't exist
i'm saying there's still a lot of room
there because
i know a lot of people i have a lot of
friends who are doing ecommerce right we
host club ltv
there's you know 75 to 100 e-commerce
brands each doing over a million dollars
a year in there
and every single one of them i think has
the same problem which is that
we're all u.s focused and why are we us
focused because
it would be too much of a lift too much
of a lift to go figure out how to do
australia it's too small of a pie to
like
do manpower on or spend brain power on
but if somebody in australia
was like hey look this is what we do
this is our business model we
help you get sales here and we just take
our cut
and uh and so i just think that like
there needs there's more opportunity for
this and that's cool that
media it sounds like there's also an
opportunity to do it in media too
or being done in some way by the big
players it's being done in some way but
like i remember when buzzfeed
uh like were going through some troubles
they had a layoff like their whole
french office and i was like buzzfeed
has a french office what the [__]
that's the opposite right that's we have
a french office and then you have to do
things like that when it's like not
working out i'm saying
no investment no consulting fees
you just take a royalty on sales and
these are all incremental sales that i
wasn't getting otherwise
and you take care of the whole
operational headache in this case for
ecommerce about like
i just ship your goods to your warehouse
you ship it to local customers customers
don't have to overpay
customers don't have to do import duties
uh for every order they make
and so i just think that there's a
opportunity in e-commerce to like be the
the go-to brand for every d2c brand
to partner with in each of these locales
what
country would you go to next um
i think europe is probably the best
because you want um what the you know
the next wealthiest
high populous place um but really it
could work anywhere it's just like the
biggest market
is doing it you know throughout europe
now europe
is made up of so many countries maybe
that's a pain in the ass if not like
canada's the no-brainer australia next
japan is a good one um those would be
the ones india maybe like for example i
know a bunch of people in india who did
this so
uh my dad introduced me to these guys
and i was like oh wow why is
these guys their house is humongous how
you know what do they do
it's like oh yeah they um they partnered
with jockey underwear
and they just became the jockey like
seller here they have exclusive rights
to sell jockey in india
next guy at the dinner table what do you
do oh we're the domino's guys in india
what
yeah we're the exclusive franchisee of
dominoes for india
um okay what does that mean well we have
like indians didn't really eat pizza
before this so we're like teaching
people to eat pizza they [__] love it
turns out and so we have like you know 9
dominoes throughout india now like oh my
god what is going on here
it's like you know local franchisee but
for what's this called
what's the terminal what's the term for
this i don't know
you know maybe i should have gone to
business school i think it's probably
just like in brick and mortar
i think it's just called franchising um
franchising was the way to sp
spread geographically you know when your
brick and mortar can only scale so fast
uh that's how you would do it you would
franchise out and then the franchise
would pay a royalty back to it back to
the
master franchise of the brand of their
sales
and they're they're the local operator
but with e-commerce or with digital
media
it's a little bit different but it kind
of has the same problem so i don't know
if there's a new word for it
man i think this is wildly fascinating
this is a i didn't think it was that
interesting at first but now i know what
you're talking about
where uh i've heard so many stories of
the same thing but not maybe not of
india but
i am the official uh importer of x y and
z
yeah we're the distributor of x or like
for you just think about for your
business right like
would could you have sold for more if
you had like
250 000 you know or like 500 000
subscribers in japan
and like dude i think there's a world
where i would have been where i could
have made more money
in those markets than i did in america
because even though america has more
people
um i don't think the french or i don't
think that the germans
um i don't think facebook kicks as much
ass over there as it does here
with instagram and everything and so i
think the ad markets because i
i do think that europe sorry europeans
if you're listening i do think that you
guys are five or ten years behind
when it comes to some technology stuff
um and
the ad markets suck because of facebook
and google so like
if you could still capture a little bit
of that revenue i think you could
well i don't know if any of that's true
but what i do know is that it's true
trust me as you're building well i think
like everybody uses facebook everywhere
so
that's the part i'm saying i don't know
um well sorry but what i mean is like
old media
still does quite well abroad okay that's
fair that's fair
uh the thing i'm just saying is like if
while you were building your u.s
business and all your employees are
focused on your us business if somebody
said i love your product
i'd love to license the brand from you
or or i'd love to be your partner in
in the uk or in japan or in australia
and i will build
i will use the same playbook it'll be
under your company i just want my cut
for building this for you because i'm
going to private you would have done it
means there was an opportunity for some
entrepreneur that should have been
reaching out to you saying
this is a no-lose proposition you still
own it you still make money off of it
it's still your name brand i just get to
go i get to basically take your brand
take your head take your product
and localize it or distribute it here
where i'm from and i know the market
yeah
and my product's way easier than yours
it was because it's pixels it's not
anything real
and i would have loved to have done that
and i used to have people emailing me
all the time and then we had a bunch of
people in russia some people in mexico
who would just verbatim copy our [__]
and i would say i would have to
i'd find it and i'd be like you guys
stop this dude you're not allowed to do
this
and then i'd have other people who would
email me like hey can i try did you stop
anyone from doing that i feel like you
can't do [__] if somebody
takes your newsletter and they just word
for word transcribe it in russia and
they're like
we're called whatever how hustle are you
no there's nothing you could do
the only thing that i was able to do the
only thing i was able to do we had
someone do this an
italian we had someone do it in russian
and we had someone do it in mexico uh
yeah mexico and i basically shamed them
i said like i'm just gonna i'm just
gonna call you out
and so i would tweet at them or i would
email them uh i i would just would make
it well known and
my network was large enough that someone
of someone knew them
and they were embarrassed and they yeah
and they stopped doing it
but no i didn't do [__]
yeah and i had people email me all the
time saying hey can i do this for
uh spain and i would say yeah but i
don't really know anything about you i
don't know if you've got good taste i
don't like i don't i know nothing about
you
and i would just throw it off to the
side and just kind of forget about it
feel like i can rule the world i know i
could be what i want to
i put my law in it like my days off on a
road less travel never looking back